[Music]
in the biblical story of the Tower of
Babel all of humanity once spoke a
single language until they suddenly
split into many groups unable to
understand each other we don't really
know if such an original language ever
existed but we do know that the
thousands of languages existing today
can be traced back to a much smaller
number so how did we end up with so many
in the early days of human migration the
world was much less populated groups of
people that shared a single language and
culture often split into smaller tribes
going separate ways in search of fresh
game and fertile land as they migrated
and settled in new places they became
isolated from one another and developed
in different ways centuries of living in
different conditions eating different
food and encountering different
neighbors turned similar dialects with
varied pronunciation and vocabulary into
radically different languages continuing
to divide as populations grew and spread
out further like genealogists modern
linguists try to map this process by
tracing multiple languages back as far
as they can to their common ancestor or
proto-language a group of all languages
related in this way is called a language
family which can contain many branches
and subfamilies so how do we determine
whether languages are related in the
first place similar sounding words don't
tell us much they could be false
cognates or just directly borrowed terms
rather than derived from a common root
grammar and syntax are a more reliable
guide as well as basic vocabulary such
as pronouns numbers or kinship terms
that's less likely to be borrowed by
systematically comparing these features
and looking for regular patterns of
sound changes and correspondences
between languages linguists can
determine relationships trace specific
steps in their evolution and even
reconstruct earlier languages with no
written records linguistics can even
reveal other important historical clues
such as determining the geographic
origins and lifestyles of ancient
peoples based on which of their words
were native and which were borrowed
there are two main problems linguist
face when constructing these language
family trees one is that there is no
clear way of deciding where the branches
at the bottom should end that is which
dialects should be considered separate
languages or vice versa
Chinese is classified as a single
language but its dialects married to the
point of being mutually unintelligible
while speakers of Spanish and Portuguese
can often understand each other language
is actually spoken by living people do
not exist and neatly divided categories
but tend to transition gradually
crossing borders and classifications
often the difference between languages
and dialects is a matter of changing
political and national considerations
rather than any linguistic features this
is why the answer to how many languages
are there can be anywhere between 3,000
and 8,000 depending on who's counting
the other problem is that the farther we
move back in time towards the top of the
tree the less evidence we have about the
languages there the current division of
major language families represents the
limit at which relationships can be
established with reasonable certainty
meaning that languages of different
families are presumed not to be related
on any level but this may change while
many proposals for higher level
relationships or super families are
speculative some have been widely
accepted and others are being considered
especially for native languages with
small speaker populations that have not
been extensively studied we may never be
able to determine how language came
about or whether all human languages did
in fact have a common ancestor scattered
through the babble of migration but the
next time you hear a foreign language
pay attention it may not be as foreign
as you think
you
[Music]